the Pleistocene Park idea that the CMOS
have been working on for 30 years is
that basically the animal biomass in the
entire Arctic and subarctic used to be a
hundred times greater than it is now
it's basically depauperate now in
ecological terms and what they're doing
is putting a density of grazing animals
akuti and horses which you saw in that
first video reindeer buffalo they're
trying to get some more American bison
their musk ox and so on get them in the
density they used to be they trampled
the snow which they need to do to get at
the grass in the winter that gets the
cold down through the snow tree the
permafrost keeping it cold and grazers
make grass that's how it works in Africa
that's how it works everywhere
mammoths will not be completely required
to get the mammoths step back but it
would help because elephants generally
are good at ripping up trees or knocking
down trees and then that opens it up for
the other grazers to come in and turn it
into grassland that that's a normal
cycle the way it develops and say the
Serengeti in Africa the richness of
animal life that you see in those parts
of protected Africa now are like it used
to be all over the world including here
and including the Arctic and subarctic
and one of the reasons there would
there's hope of getting the woolly
mammoths back once we go through this
process is that it's wonderful habitat
for them now with the other animals to
help turn in a grassland they're grazers
themselves and you get enough of all
these animals back you get the amendment
step back which is grass which fixes
carbon replacing the tundra which is
currently thawing and releasing
greenhouse gases this is what's her name
Ariana lysyl from George church's lab
and she's looking very common study but
she's thrilled out of her mind
because this is a the trunk of a female
mammoth who was 60 years old when she
died some 10 or 12 thousand years plus
ago and because of that cold permafrost
and all of that this is not a fossil
this is the trunk of the animal and for
me I mean in a way the trunk is this
sort of most elephant part of an
elephant and she just sort of take hold
of wearing the blue gloves the trunk of
this female mammoth from that long ago
was a personal connection across that
time to how it used to be and to how it
might be again when features exactly
like her can come back to that part of
the world
now what Arianna is doing is cutting off
pieces of tissue I wish she got from
this and from another museum and taking
it back to Harvard this is one of those
things where the Russians say well
there's a whole lot of rules and you got
to get this that and other permissions
and it's basically hopeless don't even
think of taking tissue with you which
you like a plastic bag to carry it in
and we gradually call and that's how
things work
the answer is Austin yet but there's a
way
[Music]